in this video today i'm going to explain
exactly how you can master archicad wall
types and compositions i'm going to run
you from a basic noob to an absolute
expert
in hopefully under 10 minutes maybe 15
let's see how we go what's going on guys
my name is david thomas and welcome back
to the channel if you're new here
firstly thank you so much for joining me
on this channel we talk all things
architecture and technology if that
interests you smash that subscribe
button down below for a brand new video
every single monday
now today we're talking about archicad
wall types wall compositions and
everything you need to know how to
create the perfect wall system i'm not
going to hold you for too long on this
screen let's turn around and get started
with today's tutorial so we started with
the archive template open in front of us
here today and it doesn't matter what
template you're using at the moment i'm
working on creating my very own archicad
template for you guys to be able to
download so this is just all part of the
process basically if you're new to
archicad what we're going to be talking
about today is the wall tool so over
here on the left hand side panel the
very first icon at the top is going to
be the wall tool if we click on the wall
tool and then select our settings dialog
box at the top it's going to open up all
of the settings for our walls now
looking at this dialog box there's an
overwhelming amount of information but
let's break it down here at the front we
have our home story where that wall is
basically going to start if we want to
increase the height of that wall we can
use it here so say zero is our ground
floor we want to make sure that wall
floats 300 millimeters for whatever
reason we type in 300 in this instance
we don't need that simply back to zero
is absolutely fine now at the same time
this is linked to the first floor
ceiling so if we were to adjust our
ceiling heights automatically this would
update automatically as well that's
something i prefer to use but if you
don't like to and you want to adjust all
of your wall heights individually you
can simply change that to not linked and
you have full control over your wall
heights on the right hand side at the
top we have our three different type of
wall composites basically we have a
basic construction type which can be
anything that is set up in our original
boxes or we can have a composition that
composition is what i'm going to be
walking you through today creating new
compositions analyzing and changing all
the hatches and the details in that in
the default you have a series of walls
and wall types created automatically for
you so for example we could have a 190
millimeter block external wall or we
could use something as generic as a 70
meter stud partition wall no matter what
you choose it's going to automatically
update and give you the overall width of
that wall as well
including the fiber sheet cement on that
side there so that wall even though it's
190 millimeters of block work it's 222
millimeters overall in total this
section down here is basically going to
tell us what elements we can use that
for so for instance this generic roof
slash wall slab can be used as a wall a
slab a roof or a shell whereas most of
the wall types created by default and
archicad are just walls now we have
additional settings down below here
which basically allow us to manipulate
that wall further very simple very
self-explanatory if you hover over them
it's going to tell you exactly what they
do the reference line down below depends
how you wish to use and how you wish to
set up archicad it will always dimension
from the core itself and it won't
dimension the actual plasterboard or the
finish if you set it up that way so it's
important that you use your reference
line according to how you work for me
personally i have it on the outside face
because if for any reason that wall type
grows it means the room inside shrinks
now for me personally that is very
useful because if you already have a
development approval from the local
authorities it means that you don't need
to go back and reapply because the wall
has moved and the perimeter boundaries
have changed instead you're just
decreasing the internal space and it's
not a big problem from a regulation
point of view so you can make that
conscious decision to move forward or
not down below we have some additional
settings basically of how it is
represented on the ground floor plan and
these aren't really too important at the
very start everything is set up as it
needs to be you don't need to worry
about them at all but to run through
them show all stories floor plan display
what kind of style projections and the
colors of the line weights we also have
the full ability to change and override
the surfaces so the outside edge and
inside faces can be completely
overwritten to whatever material we want
they won't automatically be translated
to the 190 millimeter block work wall so
that's basically everything we need to
understand in the wall settings panel
and if we click ok and click once hold
shift and click again
and then click a final time to finalize
our wall you'll see that we've created
our very first wall
the marquee tool selecting that wall
right clicking show in marquee
we can see that we've created a 3d
version of that exact wall now just like
you saw in that sectional detail at the
front there's your 190mm block work and
there's your five cement sheet on the
outside it does mean that if we click on
that wall and go up to our toolbar at
the top and as an instance let's change
it to a 90 ml block work it
automatically changes and as i mentioned
that outside leaf that blue line being a
reference line means that regardless of
what i do that wall is only going to
grow inwards it's not going to grow
outwards at all now to continue editing
this wall and to have a little bit more
freedom let's say we want to create our
own wall type so if we wanted to create
our own wall type what you need to do is
come up to window you need to come down
to toolbars and then you need to go to
attributes activating attributes will
activate this brand new palette which
allows us to manipulate line types
hatches fills and wall compositions
now you need to know a lot of these
elements to create one new wall so i'm
going to walk you through them step by
step now if you're in the architecture
industry drafting documenting or doing
anything architectural you're definitely
going to want to check out the first
link in the description below basically
it is a series of digital products and
digital downloads that's going to allow
you to elevate your architecture to the
next level as an example if you are
documenting and need a construction
checklist to make sure you don't miss
anything from the most basic rookie
errors to the most expert details that
builders are going to ask you on site
that construction checklist is down
below as well first of all we have our
lines and if we click on our line type
you're going to see a brand new dialog
box open again we basically have a
series of lines automatically created
for us and for most walls we don't
really have to worry about it we just go
solid line or we can start replicating
new lines in here this isn't something
that we're going to need for wall type
so i'm simply going to press cancel next
to line types we have our fields the
fields is basically going to allow us to
control
what that wall type looks on the floor
plan so the brickwork will have a 45
degree hatch the timber stud will have
again a timber stud hatch and everything
is going to be representative based on
what we're using so as you can see we
have a number of different styles here
so if i was to go to masonry block as an
example you would see that the on-screen
pattern is that 45 degree line the
pattern size is 1.8 by 1.8 and rotated
45 degrees we can simply change that by
going new and let's call that custom
brick just for the time being i can
change this on-screen pattern by
pressing and holding removing all of
those on-screen lines let's say for some
weird reason we just want a flat brick
not possible
not practical but that's okay and we can
change our rotation to zero that
automatically changes our custom brick
work wall now again that field type is
completely wrong not an industry
standard not at all used in practice
globally at all but that is a very
simple way that you can change an
on-screen pattern i do recommend looking
for something similar when trying to
recreate something because it's a lot
simpler to create something that is very
similar than to start from scratch next
we have our building materials dialog
box which is again very critical to this
entire project along the left-hand panel
you're going to see all sorts of
different building materials from
plasterboard to insulation to masonry
brick and everything in between
now in archicad it is automatically set
up with the default internationally
recognized hatch for each of them so
this is something that you really want
to stick to as an example brickwork
has a double line hatch whereas a brick
finish so a face brick will have that
continuous 45 degree at even spacing now
each of these are critically important
in the next step and we can go ahead and
change these out manipulate them adjust
them as we see fit so if we wanted all
of our walls as an instance that were
originally brick walls that had red
brick to all of a sudden have a
herringbone pattern we can simply change
them in this setting and it will change
the entire project rather than
individually one by one last but not
least in this section is the
intersection priority if you ever have
the issue where two walls aren't
aligning because they're two different
material types they're two different
compositions it's most likely going to
be your intersection priority if it's
too strong it's going to intersect and
override everything if it's too weak
it's basically never going to connect
those walls no matter how hard you try
so your intersection priority is very
critical and very important depending on
what kind of surface and what kind of
material you're using so as an example
structural concrete is always going to
be far superior to brickwork so your
brick is always going to sit on top it's
never going to actually combine with
that structural concrete so therefore it
has a stronger intersection priority
now all of that now comes into play when
we come into our wall compositions tab
this basically lets us create a brand
new wall and it's super super simple
even though all of that may have been
extremely complicated to create a new
wall can be basically done in a matter
of seconds so as an example let's go
brand new brick wall we're going to call
that
240 millimeter block work wall with
fiber sheet cement let's say both sides
just so we can actually show a little
bit more pressing ok it's going to
duplicate that wall like for like what
we're going to see is we're going to
have a cement finish the fiber cement
sheeting on the outside which is 10
millimeters we're going to have our air
or space frame in the middle which is 22
millimeters and then we're gonna have
our 190 millimeter block work here i've
said that we have a 240 millimeter block
work i don't need the air cavity in the
middle because it's going to be a direct
fix to that brick wall and then i want
to duplicate this fiber cement sheet so
let's go insert skin click on that one
and drag that below and as you can see
over here on the right hand side that
depicts what it's going to look like in
the floor plan and the surfaces so all
of a sudden we have two fiber cement
sheets a 250mm block where sorry 240
millimeter block work in the middle an
overall size of 260. like previously
discussed it can be used only with the
wall but if we wanted to use this
specific composite for a slab for
example we could create a slab that had
tiles on top and plasterboard underneath
that's something we can get into in
another video we could easily do the
same information on this section here
now if i was to click ok click on this
wall and change that to my magical brand
new 240 millimeter block work external
wall fiber cement both sides it'll
automatically change to our block work
wall plasterboard plasterboard now
continuing on with that trend and
utilizing our brand new toolbars
if i was to click on this wall go back
to my building materials
find the brickwork that we're using in
the middle which is concrete block
structural automatically highlighted for
us when we're selecting the wall
and then as an example change that to
herringbone pattern and click ok
the internal leaf of that will change
completely for every single wall type
and very similar if we were to do the
same thing go back into it change our
brick structural to just concrete 23
again it'll change back to that block
work system that's the case if you want
to change all of the walls at once if
you simply just want to change one of
the leaves for example you can come into
override surfaces pick whatever color
you want let's pick a random green color
press ok
and our wall is now green but that
actual wall type itself if i was to
create a new one so wall
1 240 anything unchanged double click it
remains identical until i decide to
change those parameters
myself and click into it and that's
basically everything that is to know
about walls wall compositions and wall
types in archicad from a structural
point of view it is very simple very
very user friendly to understand if we
click both those walls press control i
they will intersect together a lot of
people keep asking how does that work up
the top there's this little intersect
toolbar so if that control i doesn't
work for you that's exactly where you're
going to find it anyway that is all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video if
you did make sure you smash that like
button for the youtube algorithm and hit
the subscribe button if you want to see
a new video every single week but like i
said that is all from me so i'll see you
next monday